according to a new poll a majority of
Americans including a large percentage
of non-vaccinated Americans actually are
okay with vaccine mandates
this is remarkable here it is
according to a late July Morning consult
poll 56 percent of adults said employers
should probably or definitely require
covid-19 vaccinations for their
employees and customers only 32 percent
said they probably or definitely should
not that confidence extends to schools
too last month Gallup found that 60
percent of Americans supported mandatory
vaccines for high school students and 56
percent supported them for middle school
students although among K-12 parents
those numbers were notably lower 47 and
43 percent respectively
and 28 of unvaccinated people actually
support mandatory vaccines
so all this fear-mongering that we see
coming from the right mostly there is
still some coming from some folks who
claim to be on the left but
it's all
for lack of a better term
nonsense it's BS we don't want Mass
mandates actually look at the polls
people do they're okay with it they
don't see it as a violation of their
freedom
they see it as protecting other people
hell when you have 28 of people who
aren't even vaccinated yet saying yes
this thing should be mandatory
that tells you a lot here
and unfortunately
that is probably where we're headed I
say unfortunately because there are
still people who are hugely against this
and I wish we honestly didn't have to
get to the point where we had to mandate
this thing
but too many people fell for the
misinformation too many people fell for
the lies and so now here we are it would
have been great
if we had every eligible and healthy
enough person because that's an
important distinction to make who was
able to get the vaccine if they had
gotten the vaccine and we wouldn't even
be talking about a Delta variant today
maybe
and about that distinction real quick
because I do want to point out yes there
are plenty of people here in the United
States who are physically incapable
of getting that vaccine you know
immunocompromised people people allergic
to some of the things in the vaccine so
they can't get it and trust me whenever
I talk about things like this I'm not
saying you guys should have to get it at
all you cannot it puts you in danger
when you get the vaccine so even if we
ended up with any kind of vaccine
mandates I think they would definitely
have to carve out that exception for
those individuals
but if it's just somebody who says no I
don't want to get it because I saw a
video and a woman said it made her
magnetic
okay you know what that's not a valid
reason because that's not actually a
thing that happened and I'm sure we've
all seen that video from from Ohio where
they were having the hearing and the
woman came in and said look even my keys
stick to me and then the key didn't
didn't stick to her because she's not
magnetic
and I think David actually pointed out
on social media
um has anybody even thought about maybe
being magnetic isn't that bad you know
what what really is the drawback to that
it was humorous of course but here's the
thing and this isn't so funny
we're at a point
where most people in this country
who are of eligible age
there's no longer the long lines
there's no longer the fight to get in to
get the vaccine
they're open
you can go to most pharmacies here in
the United States
if you if there is a line you're going
to wait a couple of minutes
and you can go and get this vaccine
it's it really is that simple for those
who are eligible and are not in any kind
of danger when receiving the vaccine
that's where we're at
and most Americans understand that and I
think that's why these poll numbers are
the way that they are
because people see you know what we
could be getting this yes covet is
getting worse and I see that now
not to mention of course all of the
stories that we've seen of uh people who
didn't get vaccinated then died
one of our sponsors is steadymd primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steady MD will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call your study MD doctor has a
limited number of patients you get the
attention you deserve and they can help
you with anything your primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works you don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com Pacman
no risk no long-term commitment the link
is right underneath the video